[Music]
and going too far news too far bro best
to ha [ __ ] tits a school district is
requiring its teachers to report
students if they suspect they might be
having sex what how do you suspect
something like that the way they walk
you could be talking in class how they
smell
what does that matter you smell like
pasea [ __ ] dari man
you smell like you bathed in bleach
young lady and you're not on the swim
team so what is going on this is in the
UK this is an Oregon
are they really conservative over there
so according to Oregon law people under
the age of 18 are not capable of making
informed decisions about having sex
there for sex involving minors including
sex between consenting teens is
considered sexual abuse in the state of
Oregon moving in Oregon so two 15 year
olds [ __ ] is sexual abuse to each
other Wow why not having sex until he's
25 he's gonna have sex with he's like 14
or 15 no he's not that's what I had said
yeah but you're like weird well they're
saying now the average age that they're
having sex is 17 oh yes all right you
know what I also means that add too much
time on my hands that just means you
didn't have enough parentheses we had
this conversation like when I mentioned
in one of the videos is like the first
time I ever had sex when I was 18 oh
that's so early early early in my it
might know like kids in the comments
yeah and I was like the first time I
ever had sex was I was 18 and they're
like and I was saying like dude I was
[ __ ] late they're like that's late
like what are you talking about but in
our group of friends that was [ __ ]
late now is really like memoride said my
friend's dad thought I was [ __ ] gay
you don't let booze booze you don't
strike me feel better now they're all
think you know that's early yeah it's
kind of nice thumb and then that
pressure is gone cuz I felt so [ __ ]
pressured you did
because I feel pressure because they're
always talking exchanging about yo that
this is that this and that I'm like no
you know what that is now the an organ
school district is requiring its
teachers to report students to state
officials whenever they suspect they
they might be engaging in sex including
the teachers own children I'm not doing
that
I know watching Brett know so now
they're saying like this is dumb because
now it's just gonna have students go
behind teachers backs instead of getting
educated
yeah and informed like for example when
they were these teachers are getting
trained they were saying that if a 15
year old girl comes up to the teacher
and starts asking about birth control
that teacher has to is required by law
to go and tell a state official that she
might be engaged in that yeah cuz every
time you criminalize something instead
of creating better communication you
create a bigger gap and not people are
more scared but then if you're like hey
this is gonna be like a different type
of issue you can have kids more kids
possibly talk to teachers exactly and
then or even like their own parent like
if if a teacher has a team like now this
team can't even confine in their own
parent about like whatever questions
they might have about sex because
they're now that the parent has to go in
is this [ __ ] North Korea or what like
they're like they got a rat each other
out nobody's safe about Oregon was cool
cuz you don't gotta pay like out the
[ __ ] you gotta pay sales tax
Nikes over there too yeah I feel like
all the hipster ass Californians went to
Portland and changed it up all of organ
was Portlandia but just the hipster
[ __ ] City I don't know I don't like
this distrust that they're creating
amongst teachers and their students
students
I got a hate on [ __ ] good yeah like
there was recently there was a high
school I forgot where this high school
was but this high school they teach
abstinence to their students and they
had a huge chlamydia outbreak of course
all girls are the [ __ ] freakiest of
the all of them I think the more you try
to ban something the more of the kids
are gonna be attracted to it
got it all wrong everyone used to be
young but somehow you [ __ ] forgot
what it was all you got to do is make a
disgusting ass [ __ ] oh that's right you
know when for our sex ed [ __ ] they just
showed us a live [ __ ] birth they
showed us [ __ ] ace STDs they showed
us all those things and then they showed
us how to put on a condom but they said
that still doesn't make you safe yeah
but what we still [ __ ] hell yeah but
at least now we knew and at least now we
had our own little worries because there
was no web and be back then you just
[ __ ] and you go oh [ __ ] I'm a good age
now yeah so now I students at this one
particular school named Kimberly she
created a petition called
freedom to freely talk about sexual
topics for students and teachers and
it's now received more than 850
signatures that's dope
yeah cuz they're saying like this now
leaves like students alone there were no
one yeah cuz some some kids too but
can't even talk to their parents about
that [ __ ] so if you go to an educator
most kids can't talk to their parents
yeah if you go to an educator it's like
unbiased it's very scientific or to
whatever that nature is you know that
mean and so they don't even got that
then what the [ __ ] they supposed to do
exactly you go to jail for [ __ ]
that's the stupidest [ __ ] I've ever
heard not go to jail they have to report
it to state officials so they're saying
here that like yeah you can file a
report but after that it's up to the
state to determine what they want to do
whether it be do nothing or they can go
and do a site visit or they can do like
further investigation but they're
criminal izing it so like let's say you
you have fifteen counts of [ __ ]
[ __ ] then what happens they're gonna
probably find you or throw you in jail
just not gonna let you keep [ __ ]
although other two twenty chance of
[ __ ] you it say you're a sex offender
cuz you're your if they said that under
the eighteen it's considered sex abuse
right so that that's under the category
of sex offending right so like let's say
you have a record of [ __ ] cuz you
were just badass in your high school
days but you can't get a job people are
gonna think you're some pedophile
whatever but you're just [ __ ] their
high school sweetheart yeah
consider what do they consider a [ __ ]
bike luck in or that what about [ __ ]
I think like sexual activity events or
even if you're asking about birth
control they have to report you because
you're like she might be or he might be
sexually active till May y'all I got
nothing better to do as a teacher if the
school district told me like listen this
is another thing you have to worry about
like [ __ ] you I don't care if I'm
required by law I mean I'm just here to
[ __ ] teach now you want me to be
worried about what this [ __ ] kid's
gonna do with this dick or [ __ ] I'm not
a [ __ ] sexual police officer what the
hell I'm trying to teach biology I'm
gonna put them on the table let me see
you spread them is there like some
problem that's been going around like we
got too many pregnancies how we're gonna
stop yeah maybe the lawmakers [ __ ]
have dried dicks and [ __ ] and they're
jealous mmm maybe that cuz they don't
mention a reason mmm policies are like a
comfortable age that you will let Tiger
have sex or is it a a comfort thing
between you and him or a comfort thing
before between him and his girlfriend I
don't know like realistically speaking
he is your kid he's gonna be horny as
[ __ ] you know I mean I feel you a
hundred percent now and I'm like I do
not want to envision this beautiful boy
that has [ __ ] [ __ ] onesie pajamas
with this [ __ ] monkey on his feet
[ __ ] so I'm never gonna be possible
pedophile thinking you got a magic you
gotta imagine him Isaac is a precious
baby but I know he's gonna get a
moustache one bit TIFF and I aren't the
only ones like this cuz there's an
actual commercial I think it's like an
insurance commercial or something
that shows this little kid right he's
probably like 7 years old and he's
getting all his um all his belongings
from his room and he's putting it in his
trunk right and his death doc are you
sure you don't need help with anything
he was no dad I got it you see this
little boy just moving all this stuff
and then he closes a trunk and then it
turns into a kid leaving for college
because that's how parents see their
kids they're forever
[ __ ] baby always yeah I also know
that
[ __ ] one day I do too and I'm trying to
like you just want to think of us I
don't know what's the most comfortable
though yeah I need [ __ ] five too late
so you basically want your kid to be a
target pop your pops and then I'll
translate interpret in a way that for me
my thing is our hope that you will wait
until you're 18 and out of my [ __ ]
house that's it that's my smile that's
my only requirement cuz my thing is like
don't worry about [ __ ] right now
you're gonna get plenty of dick or [ __ ]
later on this as of right now just be a
kid it's good don't trip about that [ __ ]
if it happens I'm not gonna hate you for
it but I'm asking you to [ __ ] wait
and if you could do that for me
I'll be very happy I appreciate you
moving like 40 year old virgin don't
help because it's like you you think
about you're like [ __ ] am I gonna be
a virgin forever and I'm just gonna be
this freak when I'm a grown-up like who
the [ __ ] cares if you're a [ __ ]
virgin man who the [ __ ] cares like one
thing that makes me feel good as I go
well I always had that homie whose
parents were like super open mind and
extremely liberal and whatever girl they
brought back home the parents loved them
as if they're gonna get married
like the love was so unconditional and
that made me feel so good so when I saw
that I'm like man it's almost like this
kid could do no wrong and you just feel
like home to safer place I would like to
provide that for taiko where like every
girlfriend bring every girlfriend it
brings home okay even though I know
they're gonna break up in like two weeks
i'ma still let's make food let's have a
barbecue just make him feel really
comfortable so you could talk to me
about I hope I could do the same if I if
I have a daughter you know what I mean
cuz I feel like what I'm gonna do if I
have a daughter ever say if you enter my
daughter I will enter you you make that
choice my favorite scenes young bad boys
to where he calls a pickup out and their
wills hit there's like I can holla drunk
you know I best I did hmm I know what
about you one would you let your kid
have sex or one would you can they even
get laid
I know I'm hot as [ __ ] but like I don't
know
I got ugly as family members what if
it's gift I can't guarantee everyone
hears everyone here in the room is
talking about oh my kid is gonna I don't
know like what if they can't even get
laid if they wanted to you don't know
[Music]